Salamum guys. We're here in Barcelona
and look, the guys are doing a a
Palestine demonstration. Very
impressive.
He's not taller than me. He's standing
on tall. Don't hit it, brother.
It's uh good to see that this is
happening even here. Very impressive.
Very good. Yeah. It's like we don't hear
what's going on in like southern spa,
southern Europe, in Spain and other
places. We're more like Western Europe,
but it's good to see that they're doing
that here as well.
not here and this is coincidental like
we're just having food and stuff and we
just come and see this isn't it. So yeah
it's a it's a beautiful surprise goes
with you. So look at this
this painting to look at this I have to
say that is a very very interesting
talent. Let's come here. So you're using
your phone with your feet now. Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh wow. What's your name? My name is
Muhammad. So this man he does everything
with his foot. He's basically as
proficient with his foot as we are with
our hands. So, he's going to show us now
what he's going to be doing. Oh, that's
impressive.
You're writing stuff. Yeah, that's very
good, man. That's better than what my my
hand. I like to share my art on the
street because I like to motivate the
people. For me, it was easy to stay at
home, to look at TV, to wait the patient
and to wait to die. But I understand I
have amazing gift for God. And this gift
is not for me. This gift is special to
share with people who don't have two big
problems. But when they meet me with
really problem what I have and how many
things I can do without hands. He's
actually drawn that with his feet. What
do you think of that guy with the feet?
Honestly, it's very inspirational. You
know that you know the saying that
that necessity is the mother of all
invention. Yeah. All true. I don't know
where we are but this is a nice
monument.
Was it called Py Fountain in Rome? Yeah.
It's quite similar. Obviously, it's
closely. I don't know what someone's
watching and knows. Tell me. It's
Barcelona and the parking where you are,
but it's a very beautiful monument. Tell
us what it is all about. I'm here with
brother Hisham. Mashallah. He does
fantastic work for the youth here and
does da work. And we've been speaking to
him. We're driving up to Andor.
Beautiful, beautiful landscapes here as
you can see. Tell us a little bit about
the Muslim community in Spain, bro. So,
alhamdulillah, the Muslim community is
growing. It's growing. Alhamdulillah.
Yeah. Uh we have Moroccans, we have
Aurians, brother from Sineagal, we have
brothers from Gambia as well, Pakistanis
and Bangladeshes. And also, we are
having a lot of rivers right now.
Alhamdulillah, despite our Islamic
history here in Spain, our Muslim
generation are not that old. You know
like as I told you the Muslim
immigration came at the late of the 70s,
80s and 90s. I see. So the first
generation was really busy and just
working because our parents came without
the the the language. They had to do the
lowest of the lowest the cleaning
building and that's a honorable job but
they didn't have time to uh involve on
the dawa. They they they did massage it
and that's really really good job. But I
think that the next step is upon us. The
next step is upon you and inshallah
someone like like yourself I think
someone very capable very articulate
here will be taking that mantle yourself
and taking the next step guys very
beautiful landscapes honestly and I can
see why a lot of English people come to
Spain I mean the weather here is so much
better not today I mean obviously
there's clouds and stuff but a lot of
people come here because it's close to
England and it's got much better weather
than England much better landscapes in
some areas as well my god guys look at
this subhan allah we were just in
Barcelona and wahi I even got a bit of a
tan from how, you know, how hot it was.
It wasn't that hot, but it was enough to
give me a tan. And now we we just
traveled 1 hour out. Yeah. And it's
snowing here. Now, can you imagine? Can
you imagine that you're moving from one
place to another and there's that level
of a change in temperature? This is uh
I've actually never been in a position
where you only move 1 hour and you went
from a sunny climate, bro. 1 hour. You
went from a sunny climate to literally
snow. That's never happened. I've never
experienced that in my entire life.
That's a Where are we now, bro? Tell us.
We are in close to Andura. Yeah. And is
it obviously we've gone up, isn't it?
That's why it's like this. I don't know
what this mountain's called, but it's
absolutely stunning. It's actually one
of the best mountains I've ever seen in
my life. Wow. Unbelievable. Subhan
Allah. Look at that. And it's amazing
cuz it was cold. Now it's hot again.
Yeah. Do you know what I mean? It was
just in snow and now I feel like I I
don't need a jacket. Before I felt like
I needed a jacket. The the the altitude
going up and down mountains is such an
interesting thing. Subhan Allah. We've
done a vlog. If you haven't seen it, you
should watch it. We done it when we went
to Switzerland and south of France. Now
we're actually look going up to Andor
about an hour away from Andor. And it to
be honest with you, the mountains in
this area of the world are very very
gorgeous. this whole area which is like
kind of like the south of France and um
the north of let's call it the north of
Spain that area Switzerland as well that
whole area it's got be really beautiful
mountains it's just the way it all comes
together the the colors the the
landscapes the water sometimes you got
lakes in between them and so on and so
forth just makes a beautiful beautiful
kind of mosaic of uh natural landscape
there you can see so what is this tell
us this
Oh yeah. How many languages are spoken
in this country? They speak Catalan,
Spanish, and French. I see. This is a
bit bland, I have to say. I'm not going
to lie. Yeah. But this one I'm looking
forward to a little bit here. So, let me
try that one out cuz I think this is
nice. It's probably the best kind of
Spanish mood food they got. Would you
agree with that? Maybe. Yeah. That's the
the number one in Spain. Really? Yeah.
So, we're at the MT trip in Spain. Tell
tell us what you think about the food.
Barcelona is a very fascinating city as
it is. There's good weather, infra
infrastructure is fitted with the food's
phenomenal. So I can see why I'm not
going to attract this